voglio svelarvi un piccolo segreto
quando ero piccolo qualche anno fa
trascorrevo le estati al mare nella
splendida riserva naturale di marinello
che sorge proprio sotto al sito
archeologico di tindari in una
enciclopedia di famiglia avevo visto
delle immagini bellissime di una
conchiglia era molto grande e aveva una
forma rotondeggiante ebbene passavo
molto tempo in spiaggia a cercare questa
con chi ha infatti fino a pochi anni fa
la riserva di marina e allora davvero
ricchissima di conchiglie di tutto ciò
mia mamma era ovviamente preoccupata
perché differentemente dagli altri
bambini non giocavo in spiaggia a
pallone oa costruire castelli di sabbia
ma cercavo cavallucci marini e
conchiglie speciali la conchiglia che
cercavo era il nautilus un genere di
molluschi cefalopodi classificato come
fossile vivente
purtroppo non trovai mai questo genere
di conchiglia perché queste conchiglie
sono diffuse in mare aperto e vivono
nella c1 pacifico e nell'oceano indiano
queste conchiglie sono speciali perché
in esse è possibile osservare la
cosiddetta spirale logaritmica ora dal
microcosmo al macrocosmo tutto sembra
rispondere a leggi di armonia e
perfezione e la spirale è una delle
forme ricorrenti la troviamo nei
molluschi nelle lumache delle chiocciole
delle corna di alcuni animali nel fondo
di pinne ed ananas
ma la troviamo ancora nelle forme dei
cicloni nelle galassie nella struttura
del nostro orecchio e nel nostro stesso
dna questo grande amore per la natura mi
ha portato da grande a diventare un
astrofisico ma allo stesso tempo fin da
ragazzo ho coltivato una grande passione
per i beni culturali e per il mondo
antico
allora immaginate il mio stupore la mia
grande meraviglia
quando una decina di anni fa durante
un'escursione sulle scene di santa
venera nel territorio di bronte oggi
rientrante nel parco dell'etna
mi trovai di fronte ad uno dei monumenti
preistorici più singolari ed
affascinanti di tutta la sicilia
la cosiddetta spirale megalitica di
balze sopra né un monumento unico
formato da blocchi di pietra lavica alti
fino a un metro e settanta che vanno a
costituire una vera e propria spirale e
che sono stati semilavorati in modo che
combaciassero perfettamente l'uno con
l'altro la forma del monumento è
vistosamente a spirale e presenta un
corridoio che conduce al centro del
monumento stesso ma quello che mi colpì
fu l'angolo di ingresso l'orientamento
del monumento è speciale e su angolo e
molto vicino a quello del sole quando
tramonta per gli equinozi l'orientamento
ovest ha permesso di proporre come in
effetti la valenza della struttura sia
puntuale e non funeraria con la scoperta
di questa spirale inizia di fatto
ufficialmente la mia carriera di archi
astronomo el harchi astronomia è stata
molto importante per questo monumento
tanto che nel 2017 la soprintendenza di
catania ha posto il vincolo archeologico
sul monumento
ma che cos'è l'archeoastronomia è la
scienza delle pietre e delle stelle che
studia l'orientamento di antichi edifici
in funzione di fenomeni celesti si parla
anche più di recente di astronomia
culturale per intendere la scienza che
più in generale studia il rapporto tra
l'uomo l'architettura ed il cielo
nell'antichità studiare l'orientamento
di antichi edifici è molto importante
per comprendere come l'osservazione del
cielo sia stata molto utile per tutte le
società del passato
il padre fondatore di questa scienza
multidisciplinare è l'autorevole esser
norma locker grande astronomo e
matematico britannico che visse a
cavallo tra ottocento e novecento e che
fondò e fu editore per oltre 50 anni
della ben nota rivista nature's locker
studio l'orientamento di numerosi
cromlech anglosassoni come quello famoso
di strange nel dorset
ma anche di tanti templi in egitto come
quello di karnak che possiede un asse
orientato verso il solstizio di inverno
e interessante osservare come molti di
questi luoghi siano già patrimonio
dell'umanità come per esempio il tumulo
di new grunge in irlanda la famosa tomba
con corridoio orientato verso l'alba del
solstizio d'inverno ma ritroviamo
struttura orientata in tutto il mondo in
ogni civiltà
basti pensare agli inca in perù il
torreon di machu pichu a delle finestre
2 una orientata verso il solstizio
d'estate
l'altra verso la levata dalla
costellazione dello scorpione sacra per
il link oppure la civiltà degli khmer in
cambogia e guardate questa immagine il
sole si posiziona in cima alla torre
centrale del tempio di angkor vat
nel giorno dell'equinozio di primavera
ma in sicilia esistono movimenti
orientati i nostri antenati praticavano
osservare il cielo
la risposta è sì a circa sei anni mi
occupo di archeoastronomia sicilia e
sono ormai numerosi i luoghi coinvolti
in queste ricerche ho scelto per voi
quattro luoghi da mostrarvi e questo
breve viaggio inizia dalla valle dei
templi una delle ricerche più importanti
condotte fino ad ora svolte nel 2015
insieme a due colleghi del politecnico
di milano e dell'università di waikato
in nuova zelanda ha riguardato lo studio
dell'orientamento dei tempi
di agrigento e già dalle immagini
satellitari
c'eravamo accorti che alcuni di questi
tempi hanno un orientamento molto
speciale il loro asse diretto verso il
punto dove il sole sorge agli equinozi
quindi cosiddetto azimut è di circa 90
gradi grazie alla collaborazione con il
parco archeologico della valle dei
templi ho potuto osservare l'alba del
sole alle quinzio di primavera
dall'interno del tempio della concordia
verificando che ancora oggi è possibile
ammirare una delle più affascinanti
ierofania del mediterraneo e romania è
una parola coniata dallo storico delle
religioni mircea eliade significa
manifestazioni del sacro attraverso la
luce questa immagine evidenzia come
orientare i templi verso particolari
punti dell'orizzonte come quello
orientale e occidentale fosse una
pratica largamente diffusa in epoca
greca essendo molto utile per le
pratiche agricole e religiose
ognuno dei dieci templi di agrigento è
stato misurato accuratamente attraverso
l'utilizzo di un teodolite con una
campagna di misura estiva durata circa
dieci giorni
tutti e dieci i templi di agrigento
hanno un orientamento solare tranne uno
quello che si trova in posizione quasi
isolata sulla rupe atenea è il
cosiddetto tempio c sulle rovine di
questo tempio in epoca normanna è stata
costruita la chiesa di san biagio
questo tempio ha un orientamento lunare
e per questo è stato proposto di
chiamarlo tempio di artemide notizia ha
fatto un po il giro del mondo essendo
stata pubblicata da diversi giornali sia
livello nazionale che internazionale
come discovery news ma trasferiamoci
adesso da agrigento a cefalù dove si
trova un altro luogo molto interessante
in questo disegno
il tempio di diana e illustrato
attraverso la bellezza dei disegni
appunto di jean houel e 700 sulla rocca
di cefalù si trova un altro tempio
orientato una splendida architettura di
epoca greca costruita con pietre
megalitiche che racchiude al suo interno
una cisterna di epoca indigena quindi
più antica l'azimut quindi
l'orientamento dell'ingresso e speciale
l'azimut di circa 270 gradi quindi
l'ingresso è orientato verso il punto
dove il sole tramonta
agli equinozi ora fino alla metà dello
scorso secolo dall'interno del tempio si
poteva osservare il mare quindi
osservare il sole che tramonta va in
allineamento con l'asse del tempio ma
purtroppo una sessantina di anni fa è
stata impiantata una piccola pinetina
tutto attorno al tempio e quindi oggi
non è più possibile osservare questa
magnifica ierofania abbiamo quindi
creato un video che potete vedere anche
in rete che mostra il momento in cui il
sole tramonta in allineamento con
l'ingresso del tempio megalitico
trasferiamoci adesso sulla costa est a
priolo gargallo e qui come nel caso di
balze soprana ritroviamo uno dei
monumenti più interessanti un grande
insediamento
si tratta di thapsos thapsos è un
insediamento che sorge tra i golfi di
augusta e siracusa ed è collegata alla
terraferma da uno stretto istmo sabbioso
l'orizzonte nord è dominato dalla mole
del vulcano etna in questo insediamento
nel medio bronzo parliamo quindi del
secondo millennio
nasce una cultura chiamata appunto di
thapsos che segue quella di castellucci
il sito è poco conosciuto perché non
valorizzato e tutelato a dovere pensate
che fino a qualche anno fa
il sito è stato
usato come discarica di ceneri di pirite
dall'adiacente polo petrolchimico
l'anno scorso comunque noi abbiamo
realizzato un importante progetto che ha
riguardato l'orientamento degli ingressi
delle tombe a pozzetto delle necropoli
rupestri i quadratini neri che vedete in
questa mappa non sono altro che i
pozzetti delle tombe scavate nella
roccia
abbiamo trovato due tipi di orientamento
uno di tipo astronomico con alcune
direzioni privilegiate per gli ingressi
per esempio quella dell'alba al
solstizio d'estate era il secondo invece
è quello di tipo topografico ci sono
alcune tombe che hanno ingressi diretti
a nord
proprio dove sorge il vulcano etna
questo studio è di grande interesse
scientifico ed apre nuovi scenari di
ricerca dato che fino ad oggi era stato
ipotizzato che durante l'età del bronzo
si fosse persa la tradizione culturale
di costruire necropoli rupestri con
tombe a pozzetto orientate
astronomicamente e l'ultimo luogo e
voglio mostrarvi elargì musco
trasferiamoci quindi a nord verso la
costa tirrenica
qui si trova uno dei luoghi dove si può
realmente toccare con mano la
grandiosità della natura che si
manifesta attraverso grandi rocce ed un
paesaggio mozzafiato è un luogo di una
straordinaria bellezza dove si trovano
pietre caratterizzate da forme zoomorfe
e antropomorfe come la pietra
dell'aquila o il varco del leone dove si
può osservare il profilo del sacerdote o
ancora a l'orante un profilo androgino
alto circa 25 metri che sembra avere le
mani giunte e che guarda verso nord dove
si trova all arcipelago delle eolie
dall'altipiano dell'argimusco è
possibile osservare tutti e quattro gli
orizzonti
e praticare quella che viene chiamata
l'astronomia degli orizzonti l'orizzonte
orientale è speciale perché è dotato di
un rilievo unico la roccasalva testa che
sorge a dominio del borgo medievale di
novara di sicilia
e allora l'altipiano unito alla rocca
forma il cosiddetto paesaggio sacro da
alcuni punti dell'altipiano la rupe
dell'acqua e la torre è possibile
osservare nei giorni prossimi agli
equinozi il fenomeno del sole che sorge
sulla rocca
questo è stato molto utile
nell'antichità all'uomo per creare un
vero e proprio calendario astronomico
utile per esempio per comprendere
l'alternarsi delle stagioni la sicilia
davvero una terra molto fortunata ad
avere tanti luoghi al confine tra cielo
e terra luoghi in cui in qualche modo i
nostri antenati ci hanno consegnato un
sapere atavico ed oggi più che mai
questo sapere deve essere tutelato e
valorizzato a dovere in altri paesi meno
fortunati di noi come gli stati uniti
d'america
l'uomo ha cercato e cerca un legame
ancestrale ed uno degli esempi più
curiosi e certamente manhattan angie
fenomeno noto anche come il solstizio di
manhattan in cui il sole tramonta in
allineamento con le strade che
attraverso il famoso distretto di new
york in senso est ovest è possibile
osservare questo fenomeno al tramonto in
due date prossime a livello temporale al
solstizio d'estate ma è possibile
osservarlo anche dalla direzione opposta
quindi all'alba in due date prossime al
solstizio d'inverno natura bellezza
vitalità e tutto questo che si ritrova
nei luoghi al confine tra cielo e terra
della nostra terra della nostra sicilia
un piccolo continente che custodisce dei
veri e propri tesori ancora da scoprire
in qualche modo penso che tutto quello
che vi ho raccontato lo si possa
riassumere in una frase anch'essa
lasciata come eredità dal grande monaco
cistercense bernardo di chiaravalle che
nel xii secolo
scriveva questo pensiero ben consapevole
della forza sapiente della natura
troverai più nei boschi che nei libri
gli alberi e le pietre ti insegneranno
ciò che non può imparare dai maestri
[Applauso]